então como vocês alguns de vocês me
conhecem eu sou de bambu ge produtor
musical e apresentador nossa toca então
fala raça surgiu a música e produtor
musical e apresentador da nossa toca mas
por um bom tempo eu não fui essa pessoa
eu fui um outro personagem era uma
pessoa bastante diferente é por dez anos
da minha vida eu fiz parte de uma banda
chamada negro de 85 eu sou esse cara de
óculos vermelho e graças a deus a vida
nos ajuda e com o passar do tempo a
banda foi ficando mais conhecida as
fotos foram melhorando junto com as
fotos a banda começou a alçar vôos mais
altos a gente ficou bastante conhecido
no sul do brasil pelo privilégio de ter
várias músicas em novelas da rede globo
nós fizemos muita coisa que muita banda
gostaria de ter feito e nós alcançamos
um grande prestígio para uma banda de
santa catarina e muita gente gostaria de
estar lá naquele lugar ocupando o posto
que eu estava ocupando naquele momento
porque óbvio era muito especial mas por
algum motivo que não sabia de onde vinha
o que era eu não estava feliz eu não me
sentia completo aquilo ficou na minha
cabeça até que um dia uma pessoa vem fez
uma pergunta bem despretensiosa e que
desencadeou uma série de reações em
cadeia na minha mente e ela chegou pra
mim perguntou giba como é que são as
viagens da banda são cansativas já
estava curioso eu comecei a relatar que
não as viagens da banda era um super
tranquilo a gente tinha uma van equipada
com bancos leitor dvd inclusive tinha o
meu próprio banco lá atrás que a gente
chamava de chiqueirinho que era meio
isolado e eu tinha grande facilidade em
dormir nas viagens
se a viagem tinha 12 horas eu dormia 11
horas e é sério e para conseguir essa
façanha lançava mão de algumas
artimanhas como uma venda nos olhos e
tampões nos ouvidos e foi relatando isso
essa pessoa que na primeira
foi uma das primeiras vezes na minha
vida que eu entrei num certo estado de
presença
eu comecei a ouvir o que estava falando
e quando eu me ouve falando eu fiz um
filme na minha cabeça eu vi aquele giba
lá atrás no chiqueirinho com uma venda
nos olhos e tampões nos ouvidos
eu percebi que eu não tava dormindo
porque estava cansado eu tava dormindo
eu estava fugindo dali eu não queria
mais estar ali
o que não tem nada a ver com a banda a
banda continua até hoje nos irmãos filme
forte temos nossa toca com nenhum grande
morreu é isso foi muito difícil
acreditar naquele momento porque a banda
era o meu troféu é onde eu colocava o
meu suor a minha dedicação e todas as
expectativas da minha vida na minha
olimpíadas mas a minha eu tive uma
sensação estranha porque eu pensei quem
é o giba não nego joe todo mundo me
conhece olha lá hoje bangu de onde vêm
aqui não sei o que eu comecei a ter uma
sensação de que se eu deixasse a banda
eu ia perder uma identidade eu ia perder
o meu valor e as pessoas vão deixar de
reconhecer e simplesmente eu ia sumir do
mapa
saiu da banda não existe e isso é que me
incomodou por um bom tempo eu comecei a
estudar profundamente até que eu cheguei
em casa nesse dia bastante agoniado me
olhei no espelho e fiz isso mesmo quem é
você quem sou eu
a imagem não falou nada ela só repetir
fazia tudo o que eu fazia eu comecei
então a procurar ajuda fora de mim
estudar profundamente para decifrar esse
enigma da vida
até que um dia eu conheci um cara estou
num grande amigo meu é um grande
coaching pessoal e faço questão de falar
o nome dele aqui marco antônio pec esse
cara me contou uma história que eu vou
compartilhar com vocês aqui agora com
que naquele momento caiu como uma luva
vamos imaginar que agora que tem uma
floresta aqui do meu lado da mata
atlântica sei lá
nessa floresta vou entrar ao mesmo tempo
no mesmo segundo três indivíduos um
botânico o fotógrafo um lenhador
então quando o botânico entra a primeira
coisa que ele vê são as variedades de
flores ele se ajoelha e costa nelas como
se fossem pedras preciosas sente o aroma
delas e se sente muito bem ali no mesmo
segundo que ele entrou na mesma floresta
entrou também o fotógrafo que nem viu
planta nenhuma não sentir o aroma de
nada ele olhou e viu um sol formando a
luz perfeita por entre as árvores
ele fazer lindas fotos maravilhosas e
atualizar o seu está ganhando muitos
links
nessa mesma floresta do mesmo segundo
entrou também o goleador e por lei a dor
o que ele viu era uma mina de ouro
ele só via madeira e lenha na frente
dele e ele já se imaginou a só serra
elétrica cortando tudo pra quem sabe
fazer um bom dinheiro para o sustento da
sua família
eu faço uma pergunta que ele me fez giba
o galera qual dessas três
é a floresta real quando essas três a
floresta verdadeira e depois de muito
pensar eu cheguei à conclusão que a
única floresta real são as três
as três são três florestas igualmente
reais para cada um desses seres
e se a gente parar para analisar uma
visão mais macro e troca e transformar
essa floresta nosso planeta terra
o q1 tava vendo que o outro não tá vendo
o que não percebe que o outro não
percebe que isso respondeu um pouco
dessa minha pergunta quem sou eu porque
é como se fossem óculos em que a gente
coloca se agora eu tô com óculos com
lentes é de lenhador
então vocês viram madeira pra mim eu
tive um choque bota a lente do botânico
e vocês viram flores eu sinto o aroma
das flores e existem também agora sim os
óculos são presentes que nos deram até
nos obrigaram a usar do tipo assim o
óculos com lente de você não é bom o
suficiente para isso
a gente usa aquele óculos o que eu
percebi que eu estava usando óculos de
bangu de 8 e o que eu vi através
daquelas leis não estava me agradando é
isso respondeu parte do meu enigma quem
sou eu percebi que eu era um emaranhado
de pontos de vista
naquele momento foi reconfortante porque
eu pensei então é fácil tirar um óculos
por escolher uma lente aqui vou colocar
você vai vivendo a minha vida tranquila
mas não foi tão simples assim tirar
aquele óculos para tirar aquele óculos
eu precisei aprender uma lição muito
importante que eu carrego comigo até
hoje é preciso abrir mão da razão para
poder ser feliz
eu precisei abrir mão do apego que as
coisas fossem do meu jeito e as pessoas
fossem do jeito que eu queria que elas
fossem simplesmente em abrir mão disso
eu aprendi que eu só poderia voltar a me
sentir bem se eu abrisse mão das meias
verdades e foi isso que eu fiz é tanto
esse cheque mate no meu ego
sem razão sem pontos de vista na minha
frente eu percebi jean na mente de lado
eu criei espaço pra perceber outras
coisas pela primeira vez eu vi que tinha
também um coração mas que estava num
canto esquecido chorando tão alto que
não conseguia entender o quê
ele estava querendo me dizer ele se
comunica com a gente em forma de
sentimentos
eu percebi também que era o meu corpo e
meu corpo também queria se comunicar
comigo através de sensações do tipo
a gente sente o embrulho no estômago ao
entrar em algum lugar isso é o corpo
falando cara sai daí esse lugar não é
prático e eu percebi também que eu era
minha intuição que estava tentando me
mandar sinais
eu não conseguia ver isso criou uma
grande batalha cada um gritando de um
lado e é como neste momento se eu
comparar se a minha vida uma orquestra
onde a minha mente se tornou um naipe de
violinos o meu coração virou naipe de
violas o meu corpo o naipe de tchello se
a intuição naipe de contra baixo mas o
violino estava tocando tão alto que eu
não ouvia as violas e contrabaixo estava
tocando uma música diferente dos céus o
que eu tinha na minha frente uma
orquestra de organizar e desafinado e
foi nesse momento
no meio daquele caos que eu percebi o
que eu realmente era
qual era a minha essência eu percebi que
faltava nesse cenário era o maestro
eu percebi que eu não era minha mente eu
não era o meu corpo não era minha
intuição que não era meu coração eu era
o maestro ou deveria ser o maestro então
eu tentei colocar tentei não colocar
ordem na casa e falei jogos por favor
silence em que eu quero ouvir o solo dos
violinos
ou seja a mente cala boca que eu quero
ouvir o que o meu coração tá falando
e assim eu fiz eu vi meu corpo houve uma
intuição e foi relaxando um dia que eu
resolvi houve essa sinfonia interior que
suava dentro de mim todos os dias mas
não consegui ouvir e quando todos
estavam tocando a mesma música eu
percebi o meu e real se manifestando e
naturalmente ele me mostrou um novo
caminho a seguir é onde eu pudesse
compartilhar as verdades do meu ser a
minha música
e foi através da minha intuição que num
dia
fazendo uma meditação
eu vi quatro palavras muito nítidas na
minha tela mental música vídeo internet
e pessoas
eu simplesmente liguei aqueles pontos
chamei os amigos que achavam que tinham
a ver com aquilo e isso deu vida ao que
a gente conhece hoje por nossa toca a
nossa toca é é um projeto onde começou
com uma idéia de convidar artistas
conhecidos ou não para expressarem a sua
arte junto conosco numa casa de madeira
no centro de balneário camboriú e esse
vídeo é o nosso piloto o primeiro vídeo
e depois de a gente lançar foi um
sucesso rápido a gente até se apavorou
um pouco porque depois de pouco tempo a
gente já estava recebendo do youtube uma
plaquinha dos 100 mil inscritos e 11
primeiro milhão de vil e hoje em dia o
canal com menos de dois anos alcançando
seu 9 milhões de views e é um dos canais
mais influente do youtube no brasil mas
eu não atribuo isso ao nosso
conhecimento de produção musical de
vídeo também faz parte da nossa relação
e um dos lemas da nossa toca é que fazer
uma música ou fazer um vídeo nada mais é
do que a eternizar um momento assim como
nós estamos fazendo aqui
agora esse segundo e sempre que eu entro
em contato com o novo artista e tem
alguns deles aqui que não me deixa
mentir
a primeira coisa que eu falo é o nosso
único objetivo é ser feliz
a gente vai fazer o que a gente ama do
nosso jeito você não tem que provar nada
pra ninguém
é você não tem que fazer um querer fazer
um vídeo melhor do que o outro artista
e se a gente fizer isso o resultado de
curtidas views e compartilhamentos que
também são importantes vão ser fruto
natural do curso das coisas e quando eu
falo isso para os artistas parece que
uma mágica acontece e se abriam as
portas da criatividade ea gente fica
livre para fazer o que a gente bem
entender
e essa mágica eu tenho notado que as
pessoas estão percebendo através dos
nossos vídeos
se vocês não sei se você já para
pra notar mas em todos os vídeos da
nossa toca a gente tem uma câmera lenta
onde é e nessa câmera lenta é o único
momento em que o artista olha
diretamente para o vídeo e nenhum outro
momento do vídeo alguém olhou
diretamente para a câmera ea nossa
intenção é que a pessoa se conecte
olhando no olho e perceba que ali dentro
daquela voz tem um espírito dentro
daquele corpo tem alguém que quer falar
alguma coisa que tem os seus enigmas da
vida e enfim é uma outra ferramenta que
a gente usa na nossa toca é utilizar
músicas atuais grandes hits que estão
bombando no momento ou grandes hits de
antigamente porque a gente acredita que
essa é uma linguagem universal do
adolescente mais velha e pegando essa
música daquele jeito já conhecida a
gente tenta mudar de alguma forma
criativa e nas entrelinhas colocar algum
recado plantar uma semente que germine
no futuro se assim for da vontade da
vida em nome de um bem maior
e a gente tem também é uma ferramenta
que a gente descobriu se é muito
importante para a saúde da nossa toca
que responder a grande maioria de
comentários que a gente pode e foi
fazendo isso que a gente percebeu como
ser humano gosta de ser correspondida
gosta de ser ouvida ea gente procura da
atenção pra todos os sindicatos que a
gente tem espalhados pelo brasil e para
pegar um gancho
nesse vídeo que passou da amanda palma é
o nossa toca passou por um período de
dificuldade financeira porque querendo
ou não a gente ainda não vive de luz
gostaria muito e fazer só nossa toca mas
a gente tem muitas contas para pagar
o programa gera muitas contas a gente se
olhou e falou e agora a galera
nós estamos no vermelho que nós vamos
fazer e passou pela nossa cabeça deixar
de fazer esse programa e foi vendo o
vídeo dela nos cai uma ficha
nós estamos usando um óculos com lentes
que nos diziam pedir feio
a gente tinha vergonha de pedir ajuda
foi vendo vídeo dela que eu entendi e
aprende e colocamos em prática que nós
não estamos pedindo nós estamos trocando
e hoje em dia o nosso toque é financiado
pelas pessoas que assistem e sentem
simpático nosso programa nossa troca
também seguindo essa mesma linha de
raciocínio é nós queremos agora um
projeto chamado dizem toca onde a gente
sai da internet vai pra cima do palco
para mais do que fazer um som ao vivo
com vários dos artistas que já passaram
pelo nosso programa
nós podemos abraçar e vendem olhar nos
olhos de cada um das pessoas que foram
lá para nos prestigiar e esse projeto
tem se mostrado como um potencial
bastante grande para quem sabe ir a um
festival em prol da música da arte da
dança aqui no brasil e fazer a nossa
parte para quem sabe mudar um pouquinho
desse cenário que a gente tem hoje e eu
escuto muita gente reclamado cenário
atual do brasil e por muitas vezes eu
visto esse óculos também enxerga através
dessas lentes tudo que vocês enxergam
mas aí eu resolvi tirar esse óculos e
olhar nos meus olhos e comece a pensar
assim
será que não seria mais legal se para
cada crítica que eu quero fazer uma
música para um artista eu fizesse a
minha própria música
será que não seria melhor para cada
crítica compartilhar uma música que fala
por mim uma música que eu me identifico
me veio uma frase na cabeça que diz
todos querem mudar o mundo mas ninguém
quer mudar a si mesmo e nossa toca não
quer mudar o mundo mas eu sei que a
gente muda o mundo quando muda a
mensagem que manda o mundo e assim como
a gente viu aqui em vários toques as
coisas mais gratificantes ficou longe do
do olhar do grande público e certa vez a
gente recebeu um e mail de uma pessoa
falando que pelos últimos meses ela não
tinha conseguido sair do quarto dela ela
não tinha conseguido sorrir e foi vendo
um vídeo da nossa toca e ela voltou a
sorrir
né
então eu gostaria de me apresentar aqui
de novo fala raça eu não sou hoje
babugem produtor musical é apresentador
do nosso top
eu estou hoje a mugen produtor musical e
apresentador da nossa toca tudo de bom
sempre parabéns e muito obrigado